admise par tous s'il arrive quelque
chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois est la une un dernier week end
de tolérance avons de super réellement
le troisième confinement national qui
vient de débuter et il est donc possible
de se déplacer jusqu'à lundi soir à plus
de 10 km pour autant pas de cohue dans
les gares 1 et sur la route aujourd'hui
les français semblent gérer la situation
de francine 600 policiers gendarmes sont
mobilisés pour veiller au respect des
mesures sanitaires
et ils étaient nombreux dans les rues de
londres bristol
aujourd'hui les britanniques se sont
mobilisés contre le projet de loi sur la
police et la criminalité très critiqué
depuis la mi mars ce texte prévoit des
mesures vous pouvez selon lui
porter atteinte au droit de
manifestation quand un consortium
international de journalistes révèlent
un scandale d'évasion fiscale c'était il
ya cinq ans les panama papers une fuite
de documents qui a mise à jour des
avoirs cachés dans des paradis fiscaux
par des responsables politiques des
personnalités
aujourd'hui où en sont les sanctions
nous verrons cela dans cette édition
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
sur rt france le troisième confinement
nationale est entrée en vigueur à à 19h
pour ce week end de pâques le mot
d'ordre est tolérance il est possible
d'effectuer des déplacements
interrégionaux jusqu'à lundi soir pour
autant pas de cohue dans les gares
parisiennes pas de bouchons monstres en
ile-de-france non plus du côté de la
préfecture de paris on reste sur ses
gardes puisqu'elle a mobilisé six mille
six cents gendarmes et policiers pour
veiller au respect des mesures
sanitaires pour rappel il est interdit
de se rassembler à plus de 6 sur la voie
publique ou boire de l'alcool dans
certains secteurs de paris a par
ailleurs les lieux de culte est enfermé
à partir de 19h les veillées pascales
ont été pour la plupart repoussées à
dimanche matin font avec cette mise sous
cloche et la fermeture pour une semaine
des écoles avant les vacances ou
gouvernement espère endiguer la
troisième vague épidémique
il ya soir 5254 malade était en
réanimation
les autorités misent sur la campagne de
vaccination jugée trop lente alors que
plus de 9 millions de français ont déjà
reçu une première injection
mais dès mardi le stade de france sera
transformé en vaccinodromes et c'est
déjà le cas pour le stade de football de
l'olympique lyonnais en trois jours 9
windows
ils seront injectés écouter justement le
président de l'ol jean michel aulas
alors il ya un peu plus de 200 personnes
du club et partenaires qui sont
totalement bénévoles et qui de manière
assez spontané puisque l'opération a été
mise en en place très rapidement se sont
se sont proposés de la même manière que
dans les jours qui viennent donc demain
après demain et puis dans les quatre
autres périodes pour lequel on a déjà
prévu cette mise à disposition seront
disponibles c'est un moment fort pour ce
week-end pascal en terme de santé
publique et d'impact 9000 personnes
vaccinées en trois jours sur un week-end
de repos traditionnels ça montre la
volonté d'accélérer de d'utiliser de
travailler avec tout le monde pour pour
mettre en place cette vaccination qui
est vraiment attendu par la population
il suffit de voir à la fois l'engouement
sur l'inscription et la présence des
gens aujourd'hui dans le stade pour se
rendre compte de l'importance de cette
vaccination et cette remarque et se
confirme selon nos confrères de 20
minutes au chu de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris le réfectoire réservée au
personnel serait en cours d'aménagement
et de travaux pour y accueillir des
malades du colis de 19 ans transitent
par ailleurs l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris a fait savoir qu'une
formation express serait dispensée aux
infirmiers pour leur permettre de
renforcer les effectifs de ranimation
une situation difficile pour les
hôpitaux de france saturé que dénonce
christophe prudhomme porte-parole de
médecins urgentistes de france
vous savez nous avons ouvert douze mille
lits de réanimation printemps dernier du
personnel avaient commencé à une forme
et ce que nous avions proposé c'était de
ne pas fermer ces lits de réanimation
mais le poursuit la formation de ses
personnels l'impersonnel pour être
performant réanimation c'est pendant
deux jours c'est en deux à trois mois
c'est lire animation était fermé au mois
de mai juin est là aujourd'hui on lui
dit qu'on va former du personnel en deux
jours mais attendez de qui se moque t'on
rien n'a été préparé et là dans
l'urgence et bien en fait les opérations
médiatiques en bouillie on va former les
personnels la nuit on va ouvrir dans un
self des lits de réanimation mais de qui
se moque t'on je m'excuse d'être un
petit peu virulent mais il va falloir
qu'à l'issue de cette crise les gens qui
ont pris ses responsabilités de fermer
les livres animation qui avait ouvert au
printemps dernier le le pas voire former
le personnel
l'été dernier nous nous étions dans une
période où on pouvait former du
personnel beaucoup plus calme et qui
aujourd'hui dans l'affolement et
biens-fonds vibrionne et font des
opérations médiatiques pour montrer que
finalement ils sont sur le terrain non
ils n'ont pas été sur le terrain ils
n'ont rien fait pour préparer
effectivement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et le ministre est un des
premiers responsables parce qu'au mois
de juillet dernier
monsieur vérone lisec n'y a pas de
problème nous prouvons armée 2010 des
animations
ils sont où ces douze mille lits de
réanimation une crise sanitaire qui a
réveillé le mal être aussi de beaucoup
de salariés dont ceux de l'enseignant de
l'enseignent carrefour et ils étaient
nombreux à répondre à l'appel de la cgt
et cfdt pour une grève nationale
aujourd'hui 70 à 80 hypermarchés
pourraient être concernés sur les
quelque 200 que compte le groupe a calé
à marseille et près de toulouse une
cinquantaine de salariés sont venus
dénoncer l'attitude de la direction
écoutez ci
les conditions de travail se dégradent
les salaires n'augmentent pas comme il
faudrait
et donc bien sûr il ya un désarroi qui
se crée tout simplement
on est en train de nous on va dire de
nous presser combinaison orange a tout
simplement et c'est pour ça que les gens
ne sont pas sont là aujourd'hui 4,5
millions d'euros seront distribués aux
actionnaires en cas cette fois-ci même
pas un stock options et notre
gouvernement vient de reconduire la
possibilité d'avoir la fameuse prime
kovy de la prime à craon la prime paie
pas et aujourd'hui nous avons envoyé
toutes les organisations syndicales des
courriers pour pouvoir en bénéficier
il me semble que les résultats de
l'entreprise sont liés au travail des
salariés d'un deuxième ligne ceux qui
sont sur le terrain pour l'instant à
l'entreprise reste muette et sur le
front des vaccins et de leur efficacité
astrazeneca toujours dans la tourmente
la france qui fait état de trois
nouveaux cas de thrombose en quelques
jours depuis le début que son
utilisation ce sont douze cas dont
quatre décès au total qui sont survenus
dans le pays
et ce n'est pas le seul mais l'agencé
européenne du médicament confirme que
les bénéfices sont plus élevés que les
risques elle prévoit une réunion la
semaine prochaine
on fait le point en images
[Musique]
pour thierry dahan médecins généralistes
des effets secondaires sont inévitables
lorsque les sérums sont utilisés à
grande échelle je propose de l'écouter
quoi qu'il en soit quel qu'en soit les
médicaments qu'on va utiliser que ce
soit les vaccins ou autre on a toute une
phase de pharmacovigilance
dès l'instant où il est utilisé à grande
échelle peuvent survenir des effets
secondaires qui sont parfois peu
fréquent et tardif donc c'est un travail
de tous les jours je crois qui hier sur
une centaine de personnes que j'ai est
vaccinée pour une deuxième dose de
pfizer
j'ai fait j'ai aussi saisi quelques
alors cédé effet mineur un souvent mais
on saisit des effets secondaires dans
ces répertoires et sur des grandes
séries effectivement il peut y avoir
quelques morts ça peut arriver pourquoi
pas
ça peut être due au hasard comme ça peut
être dû au vaccin on le saura peut-être
beaucoup plus tard dans les études
épidémiologiques
c'est des choses qui reste à voir moi je
vois qu'un seul chiffre
c'est qu'on approche bientôt des cent
mille morts en france sur sur une année
de coheed et que je connais pas de bac 5
est tué sur 1000 personnes c'est ça au
liban la communauté chrétienne va passer
le week-end de pâques sous cloche
un confinement strict y est en vigueur
pour 72 heures il s'agit pour les
autorités d'éviter un regain des
contaminations comme après les fêtes de
fin d'année on rappelle que le pays de
six millions d'habitants a enregistré
plus de 450 mille cas positifs au co
vide
mais au delà de la crise sanitaire
beyrouth est plongé dans une crise
économique et sociale sans précédent un
statu quo que condamnent l'analyste
politique ou la tâche
écoutez avec son gouvernement nous ne
pensons pas qu'il y aura un changement
c'est une c'est une question de
changement de politique de politique
vis-à-vis des dpi qui nous viennent en
aide d'habitude avec gouvernement aux
pages ne vois pas je ne vois pas
l'horizon va pas comment ça va changer
c'est un pays qui a été volé jusqu'au
dernier sou il nous reste 12 milliards
de dollars d de l'argent des gens pas
dans les banques qui sont en train
d'être d'être volé en ce moment dans un
mois à la fin de mai même les civils et
l'argent du peuple libanais dans les
banques ne sera plus alors vous imaginez
un peu l'état catastrophique du libanais
mais mais ça c'est quand même bon parce
que quand on n'a plus le choix que
d'être fort on l'est évidemment en
allemagne on s'est mobilisé à stuttgart
et berlin on l'appelle descoings leur
coeur à un mouvement opposé aux
restrictions sanitaires ils étaient des
milliers en provenance des quatre coins
du pays parmi eux beaucoup s'opposent à
la vaccination obligatoire
un rassemblement qui intervient alors
que l'allemagne a imposé un confinement
partiel jusqu'à la mi-avril au moins
pour contrer la troisième vague de co
vide
à noter que des contre-manifestations
était également et programmes d'où la
crainte de heurts selon la police et
puis à à londres une autre manifestation
de grande ampleur les britanniques
mobilisés dans les rues de la capitale
contre le projet de loi sur la police et
la criminalité c'était le cas aussi à à
bristol est très critiqué depuis la
mi-mars ce projet prévoit des mesures
qui pourraient selon ses détracteurs
porter atteinte au droit de manifester
les explications c'est avec scarlett pas
kill the bill littéralement français
tués la loi un slogan scandé par les
manifestants outre manche
ils protestent contre un projet
législatives britanniques qui prévoit de
donner à la police plus de pouvoirs pour
encadrer des manifestations non
violentes aux origines de ce projet les
vagues de contestation qui agite
l'europe et le royaume uni depuis plus
d'un an mouvement de désobéissance
civile organisé par la mouvance
écologiste manifestation blacklight
metter ou plus récemment encore les
rassemblements anti restrictions
sanitaires
parmi ces mesures certaines traite des
sanctions pénales et des moyens alloués
mais surtout l'attention de ses
opposants se porte sur les pouvoirs
donnés à la police pour encadrer les
manifestations aujourd'hui elle doit
déterminer si une manifestation pourrait
entraîner de graves troubles à l'ordre
public des dommages matériels ou de
graves perturbations de la vie de la
collectivité avant de pouvoir imposer
des restrictions
si la loi est adoptée en son état actuel
la police pourra sur simple appréciation
fixer des limites de temps et de bruit
pour les rassemblements et tout
manifestant
dérogeant à ces restrictions sera
passible de poursuites
le projet de loi prévoit également des
peine maximale de 10 ans de prison pour
dégradations de monuments commémoratifs
lors d'une manifestation blacklight
metter l'été dernier la statue d'un
marchand d'esclaves harry par exemple
été déboulonnée depuis le début les
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme s'inquiètent de ce projet de loi
plus récemment l'opinion publique s'est
emparée de la question
le 12 mars dernier à londres la police
met fin à la veillée organisée en
mémoire de sarah et voir une femme de 33
ans tuée le 3 mars meurtre pour lequel
un policier est mis en examen
cette intervention justifiée selon les
forces de l'ordre par les restrictions
liées aux coronavirus à catalyser le
mouvement contre le projet de loi
les jours suivants de premières
manifestations ont eu lieu à l'échelle
nationale depuis long l'épicentre de la
contestation s'est déplacé à bristol où
des heurts entre manifestants et
policiers se répète depuis le 21 mars
ce samedi de nouvelles manifestations
gays et on écoute l'analyse des gilbert
casasus il est professeur d'études
européennes à l'université de fribourg
en suisse selon lui la situation
sanitaire est propice à la répression au
renforcement de l'appareil répressif va
absolument à l'encontre de l'esprit de
liberté souffle dans beaucoup de pays
européens comme la grande-bretagne comme
l'allemagne comme le bavoir comme la
france donc si vous voulez c'était une
sorte de dialectique typique entre
sécurité et liberté puis se retrouve ici
et il est vrai que quand on prend
l'exemple espagnol dernièrement on voit
qu'il ya des craintes justifiées
certainement en partie 2-1 et a de plus
en plus répressif par rapport à volonté
et un amour de la liberté il ya cinq ans
les panama papers c'est quoi exactement
des millions de fichiers provenant d'un
cabinet d'avocats exploités par des
journalistes qui ont mis à jour un vaste
système d'évasion fiscale est cela
concerne des personnes connues sportifs
politiques ont ils été sanctionnés c'est
la vraie question on voit cela avec 4 sa
technique
un bien bel anniversaire à fêter les
cinq ans des révélations des panamas
papers des découvertes impressionnante
sur l'évasion fiscale à travers le monde
orchestrée depuis le panama plus de 370
journalistes de 76 pays regroupés au
sein d'un consortium avait enquêté sur
11,5 millions de documents divulgués par
un lanceur d'alert des archives du
cabinet d'avocats panaméen moissac
fonséca qui a domicilié plus de deux
cent quatorze mille sociétés offshore
entre 1977 et 2015
rien que ça 140 personnalités politiques
woerth éclaboussé en arabie saoudite en
argent
sinon émirats arabes unis au royaume uni
en ukraine en chine en france pour ne
citer que ces pays des fortunes du
showbiz du sport et même des trafiquants
criminels et terroristes fürth épinglés
après cette déflagration que s'est il
passé
des manifestations contre les dirigeants
fraudeurs ont essaimé à travers le monde
le ministre de l'industrie espagnol josé
manuel soria a dû démissionner le
premier ministre islandais david
greenlaw auxonne s'est lui aussi démis
et rassurez vous il est ensuite devenu
député
or milieux politiques seul un avocat
uruguayen a dû renoncer à ses fonctions
circulez ya rien à voir certaines
banques ont été inquiété comme la
deutsche bank dont les locaux ont été
perquisitionnés en l'allemagne en 2018
en france la société générale la bnp le
crédit agricole ont été accusés de
pratiquer l'évasion fiscale des
auditions oui mais pas de condamnation
et quid de maussac fonséca rien ou
presque une dizaine de bureaux du
cabinet panaméen ont fermé dans le monde
les deux fondateurs et organes maussac
et ramon fonséca ont brièvement est
incarcéré mais pour une autre affaire
celle de l' opération lavage à tôt au
brésil ils font depuis octobre 2020
l'objet d'un mandat d'arrêt européen
mais ils dorment toujours paisiblement
hammond fonseka se permet même sur
twitter de fustiger la mafia d'extrême
gauche et de défier les autorités
allemandes
merci pensez vous que l'allemagne ait le
droit de parler de justice alors que les
tribunaux de nuremberg ont condamné et
exécuté seulement de 14 nazi du haut
commandement plus de 50 millions de
personnes sont mortes y compris toute sa
population juive ce pays
pas de punition mais est ce qu'au moins
lama n'a été recouvrée en 2015 françois
hollande s'était félicité des
révélations des panamas papers
anticipons de réjouissantes rentrées
fiscales
toutes les informations qui seront
livrés donneront lieu à des enquêtes des
services fiscaux et à des procédures
judiciaires
6500 contribuables ans était poursuivi
pour fraude fiscale en 2018 les pays
concernés ont récupéré un milliard
d'euros dont 225 millions pour le
royaume uni
154 millions pour l'allemagne et 120
millions pour la france
après 500 contrôles fiscaux pour 415
fraudeurs potentiels
les panama papers ont-ils donné lieu à
davantage de régulation
oui et non à la suite des révélations 39
pays s'étaient engagés à assurer
davantage de transparence sur les
sociétés actives à l'international
mais trois ans plus tard selon
transparancy international
plus de la moitié d'entre eux n'ont pas
respecté leurs engagements une
convention multilatérale contre la
fraude fiscale a été signé par 108 états
pour rendre l'échangé d'informations
fiscales automatique mais pas par les
états unis
alors que l'état du deleware est
fréquemment dénoncés comme un paradis
fiscal
enfin personne n'oubliera l'assassinât
de la journaliste maltaise daphné
caruana gallizia exécutant 2017 alors
qu'elles enquêtaient sur des
personnalités politiques de malte dont
deux sont cités dans les panneaux ma
papers
sept martyrs supposée des révélations
sur la corruption financière en dit long
sur les dangers encourus par les
lanceurs d'alert il reste peu protégés
malgré une directive européenne de 2018
alors que l'inertie dans le combat
contre l'évasion fiscale reste elle
toujours aussi colossal le congrès
américain de nouveau pris pour cible
hier une voiture a foncé sur des
policiers tuant loin l'un d'eux et en
blessant un autre le suspect a été
abattu par la police alors qu'il sortait
de son véhicule armé d'un couteau un de
liens avec le terrorisme selon les
autorités locales les précisions avec un
serial boris
assaut meurtrier aux abords du capitole
le siège du congrès américain a été visé
par une attaque ce vendredi un membre
des forces de l'ordre a été tué et un
autre blessé par un suspect en voiture
une attaque qui intervient moins de
trois mois après l'invasion du bâtiment
par des partisans de donald trump
le suspect a percuté deux de nos
officiers avec sa voiture puis a heurté
la barrière d'orientation nord le
suspect est sorti du véhicule avec un
couteau à la main
nos officiers sont alors intervenus le
suspect n'a pas répondu aux ordres
verbaux
[Musique]
c'est une période extrêmement difficile
pour la police du capitole après les
événements du 6 janvier et maintenant
l'événement qui s'est produit ici
aujourd'hui
cette attaque au capitole déjà
fragilisée depuis les événements du 6
janvier a fait réagir la sphère
politique américaine le président joe
biden s'est dit dévasté
d'autres personnalités de premier plan
ont également fait part de leur émotion
nous nous tenons aux côtés des hommes et
des femmes courageux de la police du
capitole aujourd'hui et nous les
remercions de continuer à assurer notre
sécurité
prière à l'officier william evans qui a
fait le sacrifice ultime et aux familles
touchées par cette tragédie insensé
dans un acte de violence inexplicable un
courageux agents de la police du
capitole américain william evans a été
tué dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
alors qu'un autre agent se battait pour
sa vie l'agent evans a fait le sacrifice
ultime pour protéger le capitole nous
sommes de tout coeur avec sa famille et
ses proches
les médias américains accusent noah
green un jeune homme noir de 25 ans
d'avoir perpétré cette attaque sur les
réseaux sociaux il aurait exprimé sa
sympathie pour le dirigeant du mouvement
national islam connu notamment pour ses
propos antisémites
d'après les forces de l'ordre cet assaut
dirigée contre le capitole ne serait pas
lié au terrorisme
yara dans un tweet le chef de la
diplomatie iraniens s'est dit hostile à
des échanges avec les états unis sur le
nucléaire aujourd'hui à mohammad jawad
zarif s'est entretenu par téléphone avec
son homologue français jean yves le
drian
selon le quai d'orsay les s'agissait je
cite d'encourager l'iran à se montrer
constructif dans les discussions qui
vont s'engager et ce sera mardi prochain
à vienne lors d'une réunion avec les
signataires de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien en 2015 et dont les états unis
sont sortis justement washington qui
doit aussi participer s'est dit ouvert à
des échanges directs avec téhéran
les précisions de françois xavier
lambert c'est une reprise des
négociations en douceur qui se prépare
dans la capitale autrichienne
plus de cinq ans après la signature de
l'accord de vienne américains et
iraniens vont se retrouver
le processus a été élaboré au cours
d'une visioconférence entre
représentants de la chine de la france
de l'allemagne de la russie du
royaume-uni et de l'iran les etats-unis
se disent prêts à lever leurs sanctions
contre la république islamique
si téhéran respecte à nouveau la
limitation de son programme nucléaire
depuis des semaines nous avons
clairement indiqué que nous sommes prêts
à revenir au plein respect de mes
engagements dans le cadre du plan
d'action global conclu à vienne en 2015
si l'iran fait autant nous avons
également été transparent sur le fait
que nous avons discuté avec nos
partenaires dans le cadre du p5 + 1 de
la meilleure façon d'y parvenir
y compris à travers une série de mesures
réciproques initial la présence d'une
légation américaine à vienne a été
acceptée par tous les participants
mais l'iran a déjà indiqué qu'il
refusera tout contact direct avec les
américains
lors de la réunion virtuelle dans le
cadre de l'accord de vienne l'iran et
l'union européenne ont convenu de
reprendre les pourparlers directs à
vienne mardi prochain objectif finaliser
rapidement la levée des sanctions et
l'adoption de mesures sur le nucléaire
pour la suppression synchronisée de
toutes les sanctions suivi par la fin
des mesures correctives de l'iran pas de
réunion iran etats unis pas nécessaire
concrètement deux groupes de travail
étudieront les aspects pratiques de la
levée des sanctions et du retour de
l'iran à la mise en oeuvre intégrale de
ses engagements nucléaires
en parallèle des discussions seront
menées entre les états unis et la
république islamique par l'intermédiaire
du chef de la diplomatie européenne
josep borrell cette reprise des
négociations en présence des états unis
survient trois ans après le retrait
unilatéral américain sous l'impulsion de
donald trump joe biden de son côté s'est
dit prêt à revenir à la table des
négociations à condition que téhéran
respecte à nouveau ses engagements les
iraniens s'en étaient progressivement a
franchi en riposte aux sanctions
américaines imposées en 2018 au
mozambique le groupe total a évacué
l'ensemble de ses salariés dans le
nord-est à des pays une décision qui
fait suite à l'attaqué terroriste
perpétrée ya une dizaine de jours dans
la zone par les al shebab est des
milliers de citoyens ont fui les
opérations d'évacuation se poursuivre
tout comme les combats on voit cela
avait créé gouardo 6 des centaines de
déplacés qui attendent une place en
centre d'hébergement
c'est mozambicain fui les combats pour
se rendre à pemba à quelques centaines
de kilomètres de la ville ciblée par le
groupe al chabaab liées à des shs une
attaque terroriste déclenchée le 24 mars
dernier qui a fait des dizaines de morts
quand j'ai compris que ma vie était en
danger j'ai fui dans la forêt pour me
cacher pour sauver ma vie je me suis
caché à partir de mercredi le 23
jusqu'à hier
c'est à ce moment que nous sommes
arrivés ici dans la ville de boma ma
femme et mon fils était dans la maison
les bandits sont arrivés chez moi ils
sont entrés et les ont tués ce mercredi
l'armée mozambicaine a lancé une
offensive pour tenter de reprendre le
contrôle de la zone
la situation est encore très précaire
mais les opérations semblent progresser
selon un responsable militaire
les soldats sont sur le point de chasser
les terroristes les forces gagne du
terrain
un signe et que nous occupons déjà
pratiquement la ville depuis le 27
jusqu'à maintenant nous faisons cette
intervention
le résultat est que même aujourd'hui si
vous avez eu l'occasion de nous voir
nous continuons à débarquer des troupes
sur le terrain à pemba ou des gymnases
accueil tant bien que mal les réfugiés
les ong présentes apporte un soutien
logistique pour gérer l'urgence
humanitaire mais difficile pour le
moment de savoir quand la vie pourra
reprendre son cours normal dans la
province du cabo delgado régulièrement
ciblés par les groupes armés depuis plus
de trois ans des attaques qui aurait
déjà fait plus de 2600 morts et près de
680 mille déplacés
et puis cet attentat à mogadiscio une
attaque kamikaze qui a fait cinq
victimes dans la capitale somalienne
dont un enfant selon la police un
attentat qui intervient dans un contexte
sécuritaire tendu l'armée fait également
par deux attaques par les islamistes
d'al shebab sur des bases militaires
dans le sud du pays un essai la fin ce
journal merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on
va se retrouver à dans 30 minutes rester
avec nous sur arte france
[Musique]
la france a développé depuis la deuxième
guerre mondiale une capacité militaire
de défense et de projection elle est la
première puissance de l'union européenne
tant par le niveau d'investissement que
par la capacité opérationnelle
mais depuis dix ans pour rattraper son
retard
allemagne augmenter son budget deux fois
plus vite que la france nous avons
beaucoup de projets industriels et
capacités en commun mais il faut
reconnaître